[Inaudible].
Belarus is a country known for being the last dictatorship in Europe.
And as you might see, here we go again.
The visual politic guys are labeling everything that does not fall into the
interest of capitalism as a dictatorship, but not exactly even Belarus,
his own dictator recognizes what he is. Check.
[Inaudible].
It's better to be a dictator than gay declares. Bellaruse president.
Putting that internalized homophobia side.
You're probably all thinking what kind of dictatorship can it be if they've just
had elections? Yes. My visual politic Amigos on the 9th of August, 2020,
Belorussians went to the polls as they do every five years.
And for the sixth time Alexander Lukashenko won.
And you're probably wondering what kind of margin he won by. Was it 51%, 60, 70?
Well, no, it was a totally legitimate 80% as you can probably imagine.
This result is dodgier than a $9 bank note.
And the truth is it's neither the first, nor even the second time,
this man has manipulated so many elections that he doesn't even try to hate it.
Listen up.
We have rigged the latest election. 93.5% have voted for Lucas Shanko,
but they say it is not a European outcome.
So we have made it 86% Alexander Luca Shanko after the elections of
2006.
Okay. Believe it or not, your ears are not deceiving.
You look a Shango is more than a dictator.
He is a classic villain in a James Bond movie,
megalomaniac thirsty for power and completely lacking in any scruples
whatsoever.
Remember this image because it will help us to better understand the current
situation and Belarus. Anyway, let's get back to our story.
In August of 2020, Belorussians had elections.
This is already traditional in these places.
The opposition candidates have had to leave the country.
Look at GenCos detractors. As you can imagine,
have taken to the streets and many of them are in jail.
How many people are we talking about here though? Maybe a hundred inmates, 500,
well, no less than 6,700 detainees,
according to the Belorussian authorities themselves and many among those are
minors.
And I don't think anyone's going to be surprised if I tell you that Bellers and
prisons are pretty much the last place that you would want to be.
[Inaudible].
Inside to the TSIP dozens of men were told to strip naked and get down on all
fours whilst officers kicked and beat them with truncheons.
[Inaudible].
But in some clubs that I go to,
you have to pay pretty good money to get that kind of treatment.
I know what you guys are all thinking. We've seen this before here.
We have a former Soviet Republic where human rights are at best optional.
Suddenly a political event brings hundreds of thousands of people into the
street. The government in response to this suppresses,
these protests with violence,
and the story may sound familiar to some of you because it's the exact same
thing that happened in 2014 and the Ukraine.
Do you remember the you remind on protests and you how that story ended and
ended with the sky?
That's right.
My three-time in a rural Halloween costume of Latin or Putin invaded Crimea to
prevent Ukraine from leaving its area of influence.
So the question we ask ourselves today is can Belarus really be a democracy?
Will Putin his army be sent in to defend Lukashenko as Belarus,
the new Ukraine today. We're going to answer all these questions,
but first as always, let's take a look at some history.
[Inaudible].
We cure Corona virus with vodka.
No, we've all heard some pretty ridiculous theories about the Corona virus from
conspiracy theories to magic treatments.
Well check out Lukashenko his recipe for fighting COVID 19.
Vodka and saunas will cure Corona virus says Bella Roos president,
as he refuses to lock down country.
He also said, although many other leaders have said the same thing,
the Corona virus would not affect Belarus.
And he called the pandemic a global psychosis. Yeah, really.
You're not hearing things from the outset.
Lukashenko was very clear that this Corona virus thing was not going to affect
him. He even urged Belorussians to stop wearing masks.
And so while half the world was confining itself,
a home Belarus organized a mass events, such as the main ninth parade.
And what happened next,
pretty much what you would expect almost 70,000 infections in a country of
9 million people, including Lukashenko.
[Inaudible].
As you can probably imagine in any country,
these figures would have an impact on the president's popularity. Wouldn't they?
Well, yes,
but also no sociological studies and Belarus are virtually prohibited.
In fact,
organizations that want to conduct political surveys have to be approved by the
government. And often they don't publish the results. This year,
several media outlets tried to do an online political survey and guess what
happened? Two things first,
the survey found that Leschenko received 3% unintended votes,
and then the government banned election polls.
Of course.
Those pools weren't reliable either. It's hard to believe.
Lukashenko has only 3% support. He still has a lot of support and rural areas,
but then again,
it defies credibility that in the midst of a COVID 19 crisis Lukashenko has
received 80% of the vote. Although the regime wants to show it this way,
look a shampoo is not the only option. And the 2020 elections.
He competed for the presidency alongside for other candidates of those four
candidates. Only one managed to reach the polls. We're talking about Svetlana,
T's kind of sky
And with an unpronounceable name showed up and her husband's place because he
was put in jail and may of this year.
And what was his crane being a government critical utuber.
So I guess goodbye to any holidays in Belorussia I may be wanting in the future.
The other candidates were also unable to stand for elections.
And that's why the entire Belorussian opposition has closed ranks around messes
Tesco new sky. Her election proposal is clear a transition to democracy.
Basically she wants to rule nine months until new elections are called.
During those nine months,
she has promised that she will release all political prisoners and call for
clean and transparent elections.
Now it doesn't take a genius to figure out that this proposal has not made.
Lukashenko very happy.
What you probably couldn't have guessed are the arguments that he's made to
attack his opponent. To take a look at that.
Our constitution is not for a woman and our society is not mature enough to vote
for a woman because in our constitution, the president has strong power. Yes.
But as you can see,
elections in Belarus are nothing like those and other democratic countries.
And the same goes for the count.
Lukashenko one 80% of the vote against 10% for the opposition,
as you might be able to piece together by now and this election,
we have seen a complete catalog of electoral fraud.
International observers were banned on the election day itself.
The internet was shut down throughout the country.
And several journalists critical of Lucas GenCos regime were expelled from the
country during the case.
Yeah.
After the election Lukashenko opponents,
which are clearly more than 10% of voters took to the streets to protest so
far, this is nothing too surprising. What makes this case so special?
Are the numbers more than 200,000 people have taken to the streets in Minsk?
That's one in 10 inhabitants.
Remember we're talking about a dictatorship where the death penalty still
exists. In fact,
more than 6,700 protestors are already in jail.
Three of them have died at the hands of police. In other words,
going out and protesting in Bellaruse as a very risky venture.
The fact that more than 200,000 people dare to demonstrate,
indicates that there are many more who feel the same way,
but have stayed at home at this point.
You're probably wondering what happened to Lucas GenCos opponent.
What happened to that nice lady with the unpronounceable name? Well.
This [inaudible] yes.
You can see how the leader of the opposition Svetlana [inaudible] sky is sitting
in an office of the central electoral commission.
She's reading from a piece of paper on what you said that the protest should
stop and that the demonstrators have to accept Lukashenko whose victory.
And yes, it is exactly what it seems. The taking of a hostage.
Remember that disco sky, his husband is still in a Belorussian prison.
His children have received death threats. And in addition to all of that,
several members of her team were also detained at the time that this video was
recorded. The same day, the video was posted this announcement.
Okay.
Lana, tick enough. Sky is safe. She is in Lithuania.
Since then. Tesco's Gaia has stayed in Lithuania,
but she has not abandoned her political aspirations. On the contrary,
she has announced that she is prepared to lead a government in exile. Moreover,
she has established a coordination council for the democratic transition.
Unsurprisingly Lukashenko is not happy about this at all.
So both [inaudible] and her team could be tried for attacking Belarus is
national security.
All of this explains why both the European union like Canada and the United
Kingdom do not recognize the results.
[Inaudible].
The elections of the 9th of August,
2020 are considered a fraud by almost every country in the world on which
countries do accept the results. Well, and this list,
we have countries like China Tajikistan and of course, right?
So by this point.
I know what you're thinking. We haven't mentioned Putin for a couple of minutes.
Think about it. Russia and Belarus are sister countries. And the 1990s,
they consider joining officially as one country.
Some of the gas and oil arrives from Russia to Europe passes through the
Belorussian pipelines and Putin,
and look at shank who have been great friends for decades.
So the real.
The question is what is Putin going to do in this case? Well,
he defend Lukashenko well,
he sends the Russian army to men's cause to stop the protests.
The answer to this question is also the answer to an even more important
question. Can Belarus really become a democracy?
Let's take a look at not right now.
The lesser of two evils.
A few weeks ago here on this channel that sends early 2020 relations between
Putin and Lucas Shanko have gone from blood brothers to it's complicated.
Russia's great aspirations since the 1990s as to annex Belarus,
but remember about Lukashenko as a megalomaniac,
he's not the classic dictator who agrees to be a puppet of anyone else,
much less be a dictator of a country that ceases to exist.
So what has Putin done about it? Well,
Putin has been pressuring Lukashenko and the way that he knows best
Threatening to cut off the country's oil and gas supply,
these moves could have worked with a rational leader,
but we are talking about Lukashenko here.
[Inaudible].
And that's when and 2020 Looker Shankill broke ranks and threatened to steal
Russian oil passing through Belarusian pipelines and other words,
interrupt Russia's sale of oil to Europe that goes through pipelines,
passing through Belarusian territory. So at any time,
Belarus could divert those pipes and keep all that dinosaur juice. But.
That is not all.
Look at shampoo has also been meeting with the white house. Again,
we explain this in more detail in a video that I'll leave a link to in the
description, but keep this in mind.
The European union has eased many of the sanctions on Belarus since 2016 for the
Kremlin. All this means one thing.
Look as Django is making a deal with the enemy and is untrusted.
Worthy.
The first big difference between Belarus and Ukraine and 2014,
that Ukraine was ruled by Viktor Yanukovych, a man loyal to the Kremlin.
He may have been corrupt, but he a rational man, we cannot say the same.
However I to Lukashenko. And for this reason,
many political analysts set out this.
And Putin wouldn't spell a ruse in Moscow's orbit with all without Lukashenko.
You mentioned before Russia has recognized the totally legitimate election
results and fact Putin called Lukashenko on the election night to congratulate
him, but the declarations and here at the time of making this video,
the criminal has not said a word about sending his army to help suppress the
protests and believe me right now Lukashenko needs help.
And despite all his talk, he doesn't have it.
Shane co says, Putin has promised security assistance for better reus.
And the uncomfortable truth as that Looker Shanko needs that support more than
ever to give you an idea. In 2020,
both the Belarusian army and police are still using weapons from the Soviet
union for years, this country has talked about overhauling their army,
but they felt too comfortable having Rutgers help. However, at this point,
Putin's unconditional support is no longer guaranteed.
And I know what a lot of you are going to be thinking.
Is Russia going to allow Belarus to have an anti Russian government?
Of course not. But here comes my question.
Who said that the opposition to Luca Shanko has something against Moscow.
How's your head exploded yet? Well, if not.
Watch this [inaudible].
But a Russian opposition says it advocates friendly relations with Russia or
other countries.
So to give you an idea, one of these four opposition candidates was Mr. Victor,
Baba Kyra, our manager of Gazprom and Belarus. More specifically,
this man was the director of Gazprom's bank in Belarus.
And in case you don't know Gazprom is the Russian gas industry fully connected
to.
[Inaudible].
In other words, Putin has two alternatives.
One is to send his army to defend a dictator who has betrayed his trust.
And the other is to sit and wait if Looker Shankill wins,
the situation goes on as it is. If the democratic opposition wins,
everything points to more favorable relations with Russia. And at this point,
some of you will be saying, all right, grant, that is impossible.
Putin will not allow an allied country to become a democracy.
And the truth is you're actually wrong. You may be surprised,
but this is not the first time a democratic leader has supported Putin.
We've seen it before in Armenia.
Yeah.
The 2018 revolution brought a democratic transition in that country.
Both the current president and the current Armenian prime minister have changed
the regime from top to bottom. What's more,
they're even proposing to change the country's constitution.
And this case Putin avoided intervening.
He could have sent the army to maintain the Armenian regime.
[Inaudible].
He decided to stand by today. Armenia is going through a democratic transition,
but it remains an ally of Russia and relations with Putin are as good as they
were before the revolution.
Something similar could happen in a hypothetical Belarusian transition.
Moreover,
there's the idea that Russia could have more influence and a free election than
in a dictatorship. Think about it.
And a country like Belarus. The means of communication are very limited.
After all,
we are talking about a country with less than 10 million inhabitants that has
been mired and dictatorship without freedom of expression for 24 years,
the Kremlin has had an immense propaganda machine from Russia today to internet
box well used that machinery could serve to propel a pro Russian candidate
straight into the driving seat. In other words,
Putin might be interested in getting Lucas GENCO out of the way.
And all of this explains why. Unlike what happened in Ukraine in 2014,
Putin is currently seeing these things about.
Putin tells Merkel foreign interference in Belarus. His affairs is unacceptable.
And the irony of that statement coming from no less than Vladimir Putin should
not be lost on anyone.
However days after the conversation with miracle on the 27th of August,
who did announced on Russian television, that he had special forces commander,
ready to act. If the situation gets out of control,
we still do not know if he's just seeing this or Russia really will be willing
to take action.
What we can say is that Lukashenko has already proven himself the loser and the
shoe of defiance against Putin, but now we leave the questions over to you.
Do you think that the Belarusian opposition will succeed in overthrowing
Lukashenko could this be the beginning of democracy in Belarus?
Will I ever be able to go there on holiday?
You can leave me your answers in the comments.
We really hope you enjoyed this video. If you did,
please hit link and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
You can also click the little alarm button down there and you'll get an update.
Whenever we release new content. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And.
I'll see you next day.